um but I never felt like that before I
didn't know how to end it I couldn't end
it and then he was manipulate like he
was emotionally abusive and then he
became physically abusive then I got
into a relationship with a guy who I
would still consider the love of my life
I'm not over him and
uh yeah I bled all over him I I I had I
had all the cuts and I was just bleeding
all over him and it my
relationship yeah so I'm saying like you
know maybe if there's more parental
involvement you could be married by now
I mean I don't know your family I don't
really want to be married I don't think
but I definitely want to be in a strong
partnership okay so I mean maybe not
married maybe marriage isn't what you're
looking for but but you want a long-term
partner I think most people do right
yeah so and you know maybe if had you
not had that trauma but the only reason
you could do that is because we took out
parental involvement because no dad's
gonna let his daughter deal with a dude
that's abusive